depuis le 11 décembre dernier le conseil
général propose de nouveaux services
pour mieux répondre aux réalités et
besoins des déplacements des usagers sur
toute l'île redéfinir le service réseau
car jaune sur sa vocation interurbaines
améliorer la qualité du réseau et amener
une nouvelle clientèle en proposant de
nouveaux tarifs abonnement et services
une mise en place progressive
s'effectuer un nouveau plan fait l'objet
d' analyse systématique afin d'adapter
et d'optimiser davantage le réseau
coralie renard nous expliquer les
innovations du réseau car jaune
aujourd'hui en place ce nouveau réseau
plus performant aux réunionnais la
possibilité de se déplacer à tout moment
à travers toute l'île graphe daily
express est soumis express adapté et ce
pour une tarification une
2 2 euros quelle que soit la distance
parcourue cette évolution du réseau
interurbain car jeunes permet encore
plus de proximité entre les réunionnais
par des trajets plus rapides et plus
directs entre les différentes villes de
la réunion
elle améliore également de manière
performante efficace et cohérente la
mobilité quotidienne de plus de 22 mille
visages
cette évolution s'applique de plus sur
une tarification adaptée à la situation
de chacun afin de permettre le
déplacement de tous et du plus grand
nombre
les étudiants les jeunes et demandeurs
d'emploi et les familles bénéficieront
de tarifs réduits
les anciens combattants invalides de
guerre ainsi que love personnes à
mobilité réduite et personnes âgées de
plus de 65 ans bénéficieront de la
gratuité sur l'ensemble du réseau
yannick bonnefont directeur de
l'exploitation car jeunes nous dévoiler
les exigences concernant l'arrivée des
nouveaux bus aujourd'hui en ligne les
exigences techniques sont principalement
liés à la mise en service d'un parc de
69 véhicules neufs inédit à la réunion
et répondant aux normes exigées en
termes de sécurité ainsi qu'au respect
des normes environnementales
l'ensemble de nos personnels sont des
personnels issus de l'île de la réunion
qui ont été formés sur place par nos
équipes de formateurs sur le plan
technique la volonté affichée s'appuie
sur trois aspects majeurs
l'accessibilité c'est à dire des
planchers bas et ce six sert à la fois
aux personnes valides mais également à
celles qui sont ce qu'on appelle des
personnes à mobilité réduite et
également des personnes en fauteuil
roulant faut les poussettes les
handicapés on la comprend en plus sous
arrêt au prix d'avant
et nous on n'a plus de contacts avec eux
aussi c'est mieux le deuxième point
important pour nous c'est la sécurité
parce que chaque véhicule sera
géolocalisés il disposera à bord de
caméras de vidéoprotection de manière à
apporter plus de sécurité à nos clients
les conducteurs quant à eux disposeront
pour leur protection d'une vitre anti
agression qui jusqu'à présent il
n'existait pas sur les réseau car jaune
on a tenu à ce que l'ensemble de nos
véhicules soit le plus satisfaisant
possible
je prends juste un exemple la ligne est
claire ouest ira de saint pierre à saint
denis sans aucun arrêt entre ces deux
gars on ira à la même vitesse qu'une
voiture
l'intérêt c'est que la personne qui
avait jusqu'à présent l'habitude de
prendre sa voiture pourra voyager sur la
ligne est claire en utilisant sa
tablette puisque tous les véhicules
seront équipés d'un système wifi à bord
qui leur permettront d'avoir accès
soient leurs mails ou à d'autres
informations
il me trouve que les médias parce qu'on
vienne branchement téléphone de
biankouma jumeaux belges et les plus
bien que le bonnet ancien est clair moi
je trouve qu'il en fait beaucoup
d'efforts dans ce but là j'ai préparé
pour les handicapés pour en prendre le
bus tranquille au niveau rapidité elle
est pas mal quand même parce que c'est
vrai que c'est un bus qui passent
vraiment il est très très rapide
ensuite y'a les plaisirs est bien
intégrée du wifi tout le temps donc
c'est vraiment c'est vraiment pas mal et
en plus ça c'est si vous handicapez et
ça c'est vraiment bien que tous deux
réunionnais puissent l'utiliser et avec
la poussette surtout c'était pas
pratique vu qu'il fallait une demi-heure
avant plier la poussette est là avec le
nouveau bus est clair c'est plus
pratique puis on peut mettre directement
la poussette avec la rend donc si je
trouve ça super génial et et puis pour
les mamans encore et puis c'est
confortable accessible plus confortable
plus rapide
le réseau car jaune se recentre sur ses
missions et offre ainsi un service
conforme à ses obligations et répondant
aux besoins des usagers dans les
transports interurbains car jaune a
aussi développé une ligne touristique
qui relie les deux aéroports de l'île
jusqu'à saint-pierre et en passant par
les zones balnéaires
pour plus d'informations un numéro vert
0 800 400 1 125 ou le www.cglpl.fr